[Music]
what is good for one is not always good
for another the suicide bomber and the
pacifist have very different notions of
the good is this because there's no
meaning to good and evil no ultimate
meaning to good and evil can good
perhaps be found in the practical
outcomes of action or might instead good
be found in the desire to escape from
the limitations of human action by
striving for something ultimate even if
it can't be achieved so that's the
debate that we're going to be having
this morning and with me three very
distinguished philosophers to help
explore this mystery of the good nemi
Golda who is head of philosophy at the
new College of Humanities in London Paul
Bogosian was a key figure in the
development of a philosophy department
at NYU it's director of the New York
Institute of philosophy and Michael ruse
who is born in the UK but now teaches at
Florida State University and specializes
in the relationship between religion and
science he's author of on purpose and
can a Darwinian be a Christian should we
strive for an ultimate goodness Namie
okay well I don't think that we should
strive for an ultimate goodness in
anything like the sense that has been
traditionally thought by philosophers so
Aristotle said that the ultimate good
would be what we all strive for and it
would be what we valued for its own sake
so you might think that money is good or
money might be good in order to buy a
house and that might be good but
ultimately what are you striving for he
thought everyone would agree it would be
happiness that got taken up it very much
under the idea of pleasure but most
philosophers in the tradition talking
about the ultimate good have meant it in
the context of moral goodness and the
idea there was that you would be
striving to Maksim
in some sense the total amount of
happiness or pleasure so that the
individual if they were going to act
well and to pursue the ultimate good
would have to sacrifice their own
happiness for the sake of the total
community utilitarianism would be an
example of that view that would say that
that that was the ultimately good way to
proceed now I'm going to agree with
Nietzsche that there is something
suspicious about this rhetoric of the
ultimate good being about denying your
own happiness for the sake of others I
think that it is ultimately as he says a
bit of ideology used to beguile
individuals who could be pursuing their
own flourishing into pursuing other
people's so and I agree with him that it
can really only be acted on out of some
sort of a deceptive belief a belief in
something that we don't now think is
mostly true a belief in God with an
afterlife and ability to punish and
reward us for what we do
Elizabeth Anscombe said that to believe
in these moral concepts in this current
in in in this when we no longer believe
in God would be like believing in
criminals after the concept of criminal
law and all of the law courts had
disappeared okay so here's Nietzsche and
and this is to say against the common
notion of good which is about
self-sacrifice and and for the sake of
others are weak and unmanly social
concepts of good and evil and their
tremendous ascendancy have finally
weakened all bodies and sold and sapped
the self-reliant independent
unprejudiced men the idea of the good is
a seduction of poison a narcotic so that
morality itself is the danger of dangers
okay so there's the negative I don't
think we need the cut the current idea
of good but I think that we do need
ideas of value and it's no good just
saying oh we'll just go back to
satisfying our preferences not think in
terms of value at all we need to be able
to believe in values and commit
ourselves to values in order to unify
our lives across time and to get rid of
a sense that we are merely the victims
of desires that are sale us we need to
have some control and that requires
thinking in evaluative terms I'll talk a
little more perhaps later in the
discussion a
what those evaluative terms might be if
not these other regarding self-denying
ones but I think that nature was onto
something with the idea that they would
be much more like aesthetic categories
categories of the interesting categories
of deep earth
might be something like that so we need
to pursue an ultimate good but it might
be a good that is a good of in the value
of interest rather than of morality
thank you near me
Paul maybe I'll pick up on a point of
agreement that we do need to believe in
values and in fact I will argue believe
in values that we regard to be
objectively correct though I wouldn't
give an argument of the kind that Nomi
was alluding to that we need to believe
in them for instrumental reasons because
they somehow do something for us they
unify us to act or they allow us to have
certain kind of social cohesion or
whatever it is rather it's because
they're real and we recognize them as
real and in fact it's very hard for us
to dispense with a certain measure of
what I'll call normative objectivism or
objectivism about value and the way to
see this is just to consider something
that is something that you already
believe in normative belief that you
have for instance that it is morally
right or morally good to educate girls
and young women and you consider
yourself having a dispute there are
people who dispute this not everybody
agrees to this and you can have one of
three attitudes it seems to me if we
really boil it down one of them is to
think that these that kind of statement
it is morally good to educate girls and
young women is is the kind of thing that
can be simply true or false and there is
something in virtue of which it's true
or false that that thing in virtue of
which is true or false need not itself
be a simple thing maybe there is a more
general principle from which it derives
but ultimately there will be some
normative claim at the bottom of that
chain of reasoning which will have to be
either true or false
and you'll have to have some conception
of what makes it true or false another
attitude you could take is what you
might call a relativistic one in which
you think what
well that's something that's as it were
true for me or right for us in our
context but it needn't be right for
somebody else it's another context in
particular if we look right now on the
globe with the people who think that
girls and young women should not be
educated well that's the appropriate
thing for them and finally the third
attitude you could have is what I'll
call a nihilistic one in which you think
maybe normative vocabulary is
fundamentally confused there is nothing
in the world that it answers to if you
really want to do things right
you just have to drop this vocabulary
and find some other vocabulary not
itself normative not itself evaluative
in which to describe these things that
we call moral convictions or moral
beliefs and of course the only real
alternative here is something like
preferences you know you people can have
preferences I would prefer to live in a
world in which girls and young women are
educated but of course you'll have to if
that's all you have to say then you'll
have to give some explanation for why
the other person's preferences are not
given equal weight
what makes your preferences so special
and the other thing is that in fact when
you examine your own conviction about
least the conviction about things that
matter to you I mean to use another
chestnut I use it because I was going to
say who could dispute it but I actually
did come across somebody who could be
disputed at once I mean that's the thing
about philosophy there's no view that's
so crazy that somebody hasn't tried to
defend it the the chestnut is it is
wrong to torture babies for your own
pleasure okay
and when I said this and I said well you
know because somebody said give me an
example of an unqualified absolute truth
and I said this one and and she said how
much pleasure
it drew a gasp from the room but you see
that's very significant look who would I
mean that's not okay
and so when you examine a conviction
like that you ask yourself could you
capture what you want to say about this
just by saying I prefer this the answer
is no I'll stop you
thank you for money so let me start by
saying that I don't accept that absolute
notion of the absolute notion of the
good but I do think that those of us who
don't accept it should at least start by
taking it very seriously I think that if
you don't take it very seriously you're
doing well I think you're doing yourself
a disservice and as I see it there are
obviously two ways that one could have
an absolute good an objective good a
good which is in the forest when there's
no one around to suffer from it but so
the one would be religious and
presumably in a theistic situation it
would be at least the will of God or as
endorsed by God or something like that I
don't think this is a silly answer
and I think that if you did believe in a
God which was good then obviously you're
going to find morality somehow involved
in it the other position is something
like platonism where one believes in
some kind of objective reality the
objective reality where you find the
truths of mathematics for instance never
was created never will go in fact it's
outside time in that sort of sentence
just doesn't make sense to say when did
2+2 first start to equal four when will
it stop equaling for it's that kind of
question is is just not on for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of Arts and
ideas at IAI TV
you